I'm a PhD in molecular biology turns mom
obsessed with feeding my kids nutritious
flavorful fun food today I'm going to
show you three easy ways you can meal
trap for your picky eater exposing kids
to a wide variety of foods in different
ways is really important by foods you
yourself are super excited about
shopping with your kids whether at the
grocery store the farmers market such a
great way to give them a sense of
control and I gotta always have on hand
my happy family organics fruit and
veggie pouches great for when in a pinch
adding new nutrition and flavors to
existing foods that my kids love which
kid doesn't love pancakes today we're
gonna make these both banana cinnamon
pancakes with a happy family organics
pouch with sweet potato pumpkin pear and
banana we're gonna start with a cup of
oats get your kids to help you crack the
eggs great way to get them involved in
the kitchen the goal here is not to try
to be sneaky with the fruits and veggies
talk to your kids about what you've put
in the pancake batter why it's exciting
today class I take sure that we like it
smooth but it still has a little bit of
kind of a bite to it so when you start
to see tiny bubbles on the top you know
that it's time to flip there we go look
at the color on that I love to serve
these pancakes with nature's candy
also known as fresh fruit a great way to
get picky eaters to eat a wide variety
of foods is to take one food that they
love to batch prep it and then to put it
into different dishes and we're gonna do
exactly that with these five-spice
veggie loaded meatballs these meatballs
are great for picky eaters because they
are veggie loaded they have flavor in
the form of five-spice the onion the
ginger so you're keeping their palates
wait we're gonna add in a red onion and
you really just want to soften this if
you don't want to overcook it because it
will burn quickly there is nothing that
makes me happier than spending time in
the kitchen whipping something up and
having my kids enjoy it it is the most
exhilarating moment for me mom like
while the meatballs are in the oven we
are gonna make our glaze all we're gonna
do is mix soy sauce and orange juice
these meatballs have become a staple on
the menu for every birthday party
playdate and any time my kids are going
through a picky eating phase and with
this set of meatballs you can make three
different dishes egg frittata muffins
quesadillas and a noodle soup the happy
family organics pouches were a real
lifesaver for me when my son was a
toddler and only wanted purees happy
family organics has this really valuable
live chat feature on their website where
parents were overwhelmed with all this
conflicting information about what to
feed and not feed their kids can go for
genuine advice parenting is no joke just
embrace the chaos embrace the ups and
downs and just realize that we're all in
this together and it is one of the most
rewarding experiences we will ever have